I was looking at another talented
screenwriters site and her name is
Shelley Gustafson calm and she says in
this one article there are stories that
you figure out and then right and then
there are stories that you figure out as
you write them any thoughts
that's interesting is that you figure
out and then write or stories that you
figure out as you write them I think
that's true I think that's true both for
my work as a journalist and a
screenwriter I mean I can go into an
interview believing that it's going to
go one way and it turns out to be an
entirely new thing I mean it's a little
off topic but I remember when 9/11
happened and I was supposed to have
interviewed John Schneider at that time
he was the Superman father he was the
father of Superman for the CW show for
Smallville thank you and we had been
trying to get this thing together
you know we had cancelled and he was out
of town and and so I contacted his
publicist and she's like no he still
wants to do it and it was the day that
George Bush was delivering the prayer
after 9/11 and I was on the freeway and
we still hadn't heard from one of my
cousins who lived in New York and so I'm
just like weeping in the car and it's
just it was just so stressful and so I
pulled myself together I go to his home
his wife and lets me in he's upstairs
watching the prayer and so I'm like
trying to get myself composed and he
comes down and I'm you know I've got
journalism face on journalists face on
you
hello how are you and he's like did you
know anybody and all I kept thinking of
is we don't know where Barbara is and I
just broke down and so you know what I
thought was just going to be this
innocuous personality profile about this
actor turned into a really interesting
revealing story not only about the
character he was playing but what
justice and what patriotism and and all
of these things meant so you know a
story that was supposed to be this you
know cute little personality profile
about this actor turned into something
deeper and richer and you know I talked
to my editor about whether or not I
should include the fact that I wept on
this man's white shirt and you know and
so it was it was one of those things
even now in kind of what we're doing the
work that we're doing we had a certain
you know focus and and an idea about it
and I think as we've gone through the
screen this screen writing workshop in
Switzerland and the experiences that
we've had they're just stepping back
from the screenplay for a couple of
weeks and then coming back and just kind
of reevaluating what it what is it that
we're trying to say and how are we
saying it and are we really affecting
not only good story but are we really
saying something with the way that we're
going I think it can happen but I think
it definitely can happen both ways and I
was open to it as a journalist because
it was always fun it's it's it's like a
discovery you know when when you have
preconceptions of what your story is but
then it develops into something very
different I think there's something very
exciting about that and something very
very freeing about it if you allow
yourself to open yourself to that it can
be you know you can go in a direction
because I think even to a certain extent
some of the things that we've done at
least in this screenplay have moved
further from what I thought my original
idea was but it's so much better and
like I'm working on a documentary where
I thought I was going to have a
particular story that was going to go in
a particular way and time and finances
because I don't have the money to
continue to generate it once it's done I
can see it's it's it's already a
different story because there was a
particular time frame on that story that
I thought oh I'm gonna get it done and
I'm gonna get this and you know the
personality is going to be great and it
didn't turn out that way you know and so
looking at how that story can evolve now
it's going to be a not you know the
story that I was wanting to tell was
great this story could be even greater
because of not only my experience and
time but because of new circumstances
and new developments and new undertones
and things like that so so yeah I think
it can I working with it with something
and and and having it be what you
thought it was going to be is great but
also the discovery of something new from
what you thought you had is also a
wonderful gift I think yeah from really
if I'm honest I'm always figuring it out
as as I write even if I go in thinking
that I know what it is I'm still gonna
end up figuring it out as I go
yeah there's I have inside out writing
and outside in writing and the outside
in will tend to be
something where there's kind of an
external story and then so you're kind
of you've got the container a little bit
and then you're figuring out all of the
ways that you're furnishing and
arranging what's in that container and
generating some new stuff but and then
when occasionally I I have the luxury of
doing kind of what I call the inside-out
where you just you have almost nothing
you have like you woke up in the middle
of the night with like an image in your
head or you know you're just kind of
this very fragmentary
thing like a grain of sand and and then
it's like you're making stone narrative
stone soup you're like here's the pebble
and then you know do you know the story
of Stone Soup you know they go around
they get the meat and the carrots and
and everything and then it's more like
it's like found art like just pulling
all of the the things from your life
your memories and what's going on and
and you're kind of building it out from
from this little thing and it becomes
something where you really didn't have
much of an idea what it was gonna be at
all and so that's that's pretty fun and
and that would again of course be an
example of figuring it out as you as you
go
you